Fiona sigue causando estragos en el
Caribe el fenómeno atmosférico golpeó
con fuerza de categoría 3 las Islas
turcas y caicos Con vientos sostenidos
máximos de hasta 180 kilómetros por hora
causando peligrosas inundaciones luego
de dejar República Dominicana donde Este
martes provocó graves daños tras su paso
por la isla dejando al menos a un millón
de personas sin servicio eléctrico ni de
agua mientras decenas de casas y
cultivos fueron destruidos
principalmente en el ceibo al este del
país
que son toda esta parte agropecuaria y
todo depende de la de la producción de
la finca y se fue todo no hay nada
mucha gente hubieron préstamo cuarto
rédito para sembrar plátano café cacao
todo se fue un escenario similar se vive
en Puerto Rico que sufrió primero el
poder de Fiona La Isla padece los
efectos de un apagón general desde el
pasado domingo afectando al menos al 80%
del país lo que lle las autoridades
locales del territorio asociado a pedir
a Washington que se ha declarado un
desastre mayor
tan mal momento y pues deberían de poner
la luz lumba debería de agregar un
poquito más rápido porque todo como en
pausa no un poquito más rápido pues
necesita
Fiona amenaza con convertirse en
categoría 4 según el Centro Nacional de
Huracanes de Estados Unidos el ciclón se
fortalecerá Durante los próximos días y
podría llegar a Bermudas antes de
finalizar esta semana